i don't think there's much debate eric
the actor
he was hands down one of the all-time
greats
on our show forget whack packer who is
one of the best guests on the show
eric the actor eric you're on the air hi
you're in love with kelly clarkson of
american idol yep
maybe we can hook you two uh kids up if
i can get her to come in here maybe i
can hook you up with her
eric loved life he loved american idol
he loved
singers and meeting them i've arranged
for a big surprise for you
and i wonder if you could guess who it
is i don't have a clue who do you call
900 times a day looking for her
have you been trying to me did you call
all the time uh your face just lit up
whose mother did you call all the time
trying to get a hold of her
dianna here is diana degarmo ladies and
gentlemen
in the flesh standing next to eric hi
hello
diana first of all thank you for joining
us today this is a real pleasure
diana de garno from american idol he
wanted to go to wrestling events
go ahead eric hi stephanie hi eric good
morning
john good morning eric good morning kirk
good morning hogan what's up brother i
wanted to know
if you were going to be involved in any
more
wwe shows he's been waiting four hours
to ask you that
this was a guy who was so full of life
despite all of his handicaps
and when he would call me and yell at me
rather than sitting there and going
gee please put me on the air he was like
you want me on the air you better treat
me right and don't screw with me
eric the actor [ __ ] fine lady
oh god oh boy eric the show isn't about
you
i try to get to you when i can i do not
mind
getting through guest interviews but
hitting through
[ __ ] like i've been getting through
but hang up yeah who needs to to hear
from you then
well it's been almost five days i've
heard from johnny and nothing
but eric you're you're misled
[Music]
the fact that you shut up and let me
finish
you he didn't put up with anything from
me and then he was always promoting
weird stuff
what's that poster you have on the wall
taco saco
that's the sponsor oh that's your
sponsor
oh yeah i see wearing a taco hat what is
saco
it's an energy drink company and then he
had
weird fears like he was afraid of
werewolves so john strauss who's the
executive producer of in
plain sight which is the mary mccormick
vehicle
he wants to come through and give eric
the part
but eric has written a letter that has
many
many different demands eric does not
want any contact with some of the
dangerous wildlife that inhabit that
region
including black bears mountain lions
coyotes bobcats spiders werewolves or
any venomous snakes
let me alter that okay you want to take
out werewolves
[Laughter]
don't actually wikipedia and there
actually are
legitimately werewolves in albuquerque
what's with what
i can't imagine that they're they're
putting their stars in danger with
werewolves and
and coyotes i mean mary has you know
three children
why would you believe wikipedia that
there's werewol you know there's no
werewolves new mexico it was a real
creature that lived in new albuquerque
new mexico
he was responsible for so many great
moments
hands down one of the best guests ever
on the show bye for now